okay so surely i wasn't the only one who
saw the head of the living tribunal in
loki episode number five there's no
possible way i was the only one
and i'm not so arrogant to believe that
i was that'd just be a real crappy thing
to do
so the head of the living tribunal among
a bunch of other things we got over the
course of the episode
this was amazing episode number five was
awesome the head of the living tribunal
which we'll talk about here in a second
because that's probably the single
biggest thing to come out of the episode
the thanos copter which is really really
cool fun fact here
so back in the day in marvel comics
spider-man of course as you guys know
has been a face of the company for a
long long time
but in order to make comics more
accessible to little kids
marvel released a spider-man centric
line of comics called spidey super
stories
and these basically focused on
spider-man from like a kid's perspective
by just writing it in a more toned down
fun
oftentimes goofy sort of thing and there
was a point where thanos came to earth
in pursuit of the cosmic cube got it for
a brief second
but during that time he was piloting
what was called the thanos copter that's
the same story you've probably heard of
where thanos gets arrested by the cops
in the end
that story was kind of silly but it was
also really really funny
i don't think we ever covered it on
comics explain and if we didn't then we
probably should but we also got the
helmet of darren cross from the first
ant-man movie of course him looking like
a giant man
so presumably that wasn't supposed to
happen but we got a lot of cool little
tidbits here and a lot of the things
that we saw
were not necessarily things that were of
any real major significance some of the
things that we saw included stuff like
thanos's ship
sanctuary we saw a shield helicarrier
little things along those lines right
small little things that kind of popped
up here and there which is a cool little
sight to see but the head of the living
tribunal is probably the biggest thing
to come out and here's the reason why
when the living tribunal was first
referenced in doctor strange one with
the staff of the living tribunal it was
easy to chalk it up and say okay cool
just a little easter egg right they
named your staff after a really powerful
character to see the head
of his character even only in a statue
form that's big
right because what it means is there are
other beings out there that recognize
the validity of the living tribunal when
one society recognizes something it's
possible they made it up
when a second society recognizes the
same thing it's because they existed and
that's the way it works for the living
tribunal so why does this
matter that the living tribunal's head
appeared in loki well outside of the
fact that we know he was real
we know that seemingly somewhere along
the line either he continues to exist
or he was destroyed it's kind of wild
the living tribunal is basically the
walking talking embodiment of the
multiverse but more so than that the
living tribunal was the result of a
mistake that was made
by the one above all so a little bit of
history here originally the one above
all created what was called the first
firmament or the first universe and
basically it was a singular universe
that was
essentially sentient now the whole idea
behind this was that the first universe
got lonely so it created life
in the form of beings called aspirants
and the aspirants were wholly faithful
to the first universe in the sense that
when they created planets they created
solar systems and galaxies stars all
that kind of stuff life
on different worlds they would approach
the first universe to seek its approval
and if the first universe approved they
would continue on if it disapproved they
would destroy it and start over again
some of these aspirants defected and the
reason why was because they believed
the first universe should learn to
understand change and growth and
mortality and that the universe itself
should die and then be reborn and
basically grow from his previous death
into its new death and kind of expand
onward from there
these ones who defected started calling
themselves the celestials and this led
to what was effectively a holy war
between the aspirants and the celestials
and this led to the celestials basically
taking that opportunity to defeat the
aspirants and then
destroying the first universe in the
process technically the death of the
first universe was a byproduct
it shattered into an infinite number of
pieces and that's where you got the
first multiverse from but the thing
about this
is that the living tribunal was created
because the one above all realized its
mistake with the first universe it
didn't need a sentient universe to
govern everything
it needed a non-partial judge to
basically overlook everything
and so the living tribunal was created
to kind of maintain different laws now
how those laws have been invoked over
the years have kind of changed to a
degree
but sometimes it's maintaining magical
balance hence the first reason why he
appeared when zom showed up zom was
basically a villain that was
way more powerful than dormammu and it
took the living tribunal defeating zom
to basically help doctor strange save
the day but you also saw the living
tribunal filling other roles across
marvel so it's not really a consistent
thing just kind of bounces around from
place to place but the important thing
here is that the living tribunal is the
judge of the multiverse basically making
sure that the multiverse stays in its
form that it stays organized and
structured the fact that the tva is
doing what it's doing right now and the
living tribunal is not intervening
means only one of two possibilities
either what the tva is doing
is supposed to happen it's the natural
order of things or
the living tribunal is dead i'm inclined
to believe the latter of the two
because according to sylvie and
everything that we've seen over the
course of the show
the natural state of the multiverse is
to be a place of chaos where universes
are being born and destroyed and all
that kind of stuff
over and over and over again and even
the multiversal cycle right the
multiverse itself will be destroyed and
then reborn
at a future point in time it's just the
natural order of things so normally
under those circumstances you would
expect the tribunal to step in
basically wipe the tva out of existence
and then call it a day but
you know doesn't seem to be the case but
again looking at this episode
there's a really really cool thing that
i noticed here so if you go and you look
at the trailer for the very very first
episode of really the
the trailer for the show as a whole
there's this scene really a couple
scenes but there's this scene
where loki is sitting on like this
gigantic throne now the scene that we
get is basically him
standing up and then walking towards the
camera which is most likely
walking towards loki himself right the
marvel cinematic universe version of
loki and i say that because in the
following scene
you have loki from the mcu who's wearing
the exact same
outfit he was wearing at the end of
episode number five so
seemingly it's when they enter the
castle but he's only walking by himself
and so there's only a couple things here
either he and
sylvie split up which really seems to
make sense or silvi was destroyed
somewhere along the line i don't know if
that's really the case
regardless of the situation this giant
castle that they're in at the end of
episode number five this is pretty wonky
man because you can take it in a couple
different ways one you could consider it
being castle kang
but we haven't really seen castle kang
that many times in marvel instead what
you actually end up seeing instead
is basically the castle of a mortise a
place called tenebre and it actually
exists in a land called chronopolis
which is essentially a place in limbo
technically
it's not really out a part of any of the
time streams so in marvel comics a quick
explanation here you got limbo in a
couple different forms you have limbo
from like the character of magic iliana
rasputin which is basically like this
almost hellscape dimension and then
you've got true limbo which is a place
that exists outside of time and space
and that's usually where immortus
resides
the idea of him being there is to be
able to manipulate and really look after
the whole time stream
and change things as he wants to we'll
talk about why that matters here in a
second but basically the look of the
castle
is not really the look of tenebre it
looks like castle doom
and so there's a lot of theories going
around that it's victor von doom who
resides inside this castle i don't think
it is i don't think that's actually
what's going on
i think it's just the castle of possibly
uh kane the conqueror or immortus or
whoever but basically the occupant
inside that castle is
a future variant of loki or some variant
of loki who looks like the all father in
that particular scene that we saw
he looks like the all father he looks
like in his reality or possibly just
took on some suit of armor or whatever
maybe he killed odin in his own universe
and thor and then just became the
rightful ruler of asgard we don't really
know how we get from point a to point b
we haven't even really seen him yet we
haven't really seen that scene
yet so i have no idea if this is
accurate or not but that's just kind of
my feeling there but the reason why i
think
that version that this is loki
inhabiting this castle and loki is
operating under the moniker of
immortus is because it fits into what
loki would do right remember earlier in
the series one of the things that owen
wilson said
is that loki stabs everybody in the back
right he always stabs people in the back
and that's one of the things to notice
over the course of the show and that's
reason why the variant loki's are so
important over the course of the show
sylvie was seemingly just kind of doing
her own thing right she would cross
whoever she needed to cross
the mission was the only important thing
it wasn't until she encountered
the main cinematic universe version of
loki that she started to turn over a new
leaf and started to become what we would
call
a traditional good guy the same thing
for the variant loki's right like they
were cutthroat they were just i mean i
guess they saved loki but it's
it's one of them right so he's like we
survived so i guess it makes sense they
would save themselves
but regardless like even then they were
like you can go and do your own thing if
you want to like whatever man we're not
going to worry about you see all the
variant like vote loki and all that kind
of stuff they're all literally mired in
betrayal right that's the whole thing
about loki they always betray
each other now the reason why this
matters is because in marvel comics the
origin of immortus is that he was a
version of kang the conqueror and that
that version of king
had grown tired of being in battle all
the time right like constantly trying to
conquer the time stream defeat the
timekeepers
failing over and over and over and over
again and so ultimately he was offered a
deal by the time keepers
to basically be the one that would help
ensure that their future comes into
existence whereby the timekeepers exist
instead of their evil alter counterparts
the time twisters and so immortus was
given like the 70
century long period of time right
basically ruling from 3000 bc to 4080
and then just kind of
monitoring the time stream and sometimes
fulfilling the charter of the
timekeepers other times fulfilling his
own goal and his ambitions now let's
kind of apply this to the character of
loki let's replace
the idea of him trying to face the
timekeepers and defeat them over and
over and over again
let's replace that with like trying to
conquer asgard or let's replace that
with trying to conquer a universe or
whatever the case is whatever his his
brand purpose is right his glorious
purpose
constantly failing to achieve that
purpose and so let's say he snatched up
by the tva he's brought into the
timekeepers
and the timekeepers are like actually
you can work for us
you can fulfill your glorious purpose by
working for us right that'll be the role
that you play and then loki being the
great betrayer that he is
killed the time keepers right like
destroyed them and then in turn
took over it may be that it has nothing
to do with the multiverse award that he
didn't start it
he wasn't the one who fought in it he
just capitalized on the aftermath of it
right the fact that like the timekeepers
had really created a sacred timeline and
they were trying to keep alternate
realities from coming into existence
and this was an alternate reality
version of loki who was supremely adept
at manipulation and then took out the
timekeepers
and then basically now rules at the end
of time and just kind of allows the
timekeepers to do their thing and maybe
one of these things whereas he's always
trying to make sure that all the loki's
end up becoming like him
i don't really know whatever the case is
i think that's loki right i think the
the person
inside that giant castle is loki i think
that may be some alternate reality
version of him or
his future self right like the person
that richard e grant will ultimately
become
one of the other things that we got to
see here was aliof and i'll be honest
with you guys i never in my life
ever thought that i would see alioth
appearing in the marvel cinematic
universe
never in my life did i ever think i
would see that it makes sense right
because aliath is tied directly to kang
and if ever we were going to see ailee
off we would see it in the loki series
so here's the thing about how alioth and
all this stuff works right so
in previous videos we've talked about
temporal empires
and i tell people the easiest way to
understand this is to look at the past
of the earth itself where you had like
the british empire and the spanish
empire and the french empire and how
they would go to war with each other
imagine that on a multiversal scale and
you basically have the empire of the tva
for lack of a better word then you have
the empire of king and then you have the
empire of alia different things like
that so alieth was basically
the first being to break away from a
linear progression throughout the
timeline which is to say
being born living some number of years
and then dying and then in doing that
basically managed to find a way to kind
of permeate the entirety of the timeline
and actually create branching off
universes what this means is that the
multiversal
empire of aelioth is colossal about
three times as big as kings
and in fact alioth is so immense in
terms of its form and function
the fact that anything that goes into it
basically gets absorbed and dies that
kang
actually doesn't want to have anything
to do with alioth in fact king avoids
aelioth right so
think of the off is like the south side
of chicago it's basically what it is
but the whole point here is that alioth
is a force to be reckoned with now
seeing the depiction in the loki tv show
as what's basically a guard dog at the
edge of time
is interesting honestly i'm not so
partial to alien off that i'm upset
about it doesn't really matter to me
it's kind of intriguing but at the very
least it's a cool thing to see this
wildly obscure character that's appeared
maybe 15 times over the course of marvel
comics
being thrown into the loki tv series
because again it really all points the
finger towards king now speaking of king
and really more immortus than kang
here's the theory that we have
now i like the idea of this version of
loki
basically being a mortise because it
tidies everything up right
time travel is confusing enough i mean
look at how many people were confused
and baffled by the events of avengers in
the game right for the most part
people who are watching these shows and
these these movies are not people who
are well versed in how this stuff works
in comics they're soccer moms and hockey
dads right they're just sitting down and
watching this because it just looks
interesting
and you have to cater to that audience
and so i think bringing in immortus as
some version of kang
a character that we haven't seen yet and
then through a whole slew of time travel
escapades
they all kind of end up becoming more or
less the same person but they're not
really the same person
they're a little bit different because
they exist at different points in time
that'll confuse a hell out of people
i think a far simpler approach to this
is to say this variant version of loki
is basically going by the moniker of
immortus just operating under the name
of
immortus now maybe it got it from kang
because that's the name that kang used
at one point over his lifespan but the
reality is
invoking someone like kang from the
marvel comics
landscape kind of adapting it as a
one-to-one would confuse the hell out of
people
it confuses me at times and i've been
reading comics for 25 years so like
imagine what it's going to do to the
average person
kang is a tough nut to crack so i think
separating a mortise from
kang is probably the best decision that
marvel could make here i don't know what
it
it's it's interesting man i love this
this this is the crazy thing we're five
episodes into this show
and i still don't fully know exactly how
things are going to play out usually you
know by you by the time you get to this
point right usually you know how things
are going to play it's the same thing
with one division right by the time you
got to like the eighth episode you were
like okay so we pretty much know how
this how this
the series is gonna end right we know
how things are gonna unfold she'll
become the scrub which
she'll take off into the multiverse in
order to probably save her kids life
like i mean you kind of knew what
direction things were gonna go on and
this
i have no idea man i have no earthly
clue the one big takeaway that i think
is gonna happen from this is that
if we go with the idea that the tva
really is fulfilling its role which it
looks like it is because of the void
that they're actually pruning the
timeline of things that aren't supposed
to be there and keeping the timeline on
the straight and narrow that the tva
will be destroyed at the end of the
series and with nobody keeping the
timeline in check
it'll descend into absolute chaos and so
while that will
lead into doctor strange too multiverse
and madness and i don't think it's the
definitive reason why the multiverse of
madness is happening i think it's one of
the reasons why it's happening right
i think the the idea of the plot of
doctor strange two and the multiverse of
madness taking place
it's just a bunch of things happening
all at the same time right like
multiversal imbalance all just kind of
happening at the same time right like
the
inmates are running the asylum is
essentially what it would be
i don't know let me know what you guys
think down in the comments section i've
rambled enough
anyway thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace